- Bakhmout, Soledar, Vouhledar :
des villes ukrainiennes
du Donbass, aujourd'hui
synonymes d'enfer sur Terre.
Mais pour Daniel Wilk, ce sont
des destinations régulières.
Originaire de l'Ouest canadien,
Daniel est arrivé en Ukraine
il y a près d'un an,
bien décidé à faire sa part.
Valentina Katasonova par
exemple s'est finalement laissé
convaincre de quitter sa maison,
trop près des combats,
pour aller vivre en sécurité
dans l'ouest du pays.
"Ce sont des bonnes personnes,
très braves, dit-elle.
Ce n'est pas tout le monde
qui peut faire ce qu'ils font.
Ce sont des anges!"
Mais l'idéal humanitairede Dan:
toutes ses économies
y ont passé.
Alors, pour financer
ses activités, il a commencé
à filmer ses interventions,
à publier des vidéos
sur son compte Instagram
pour mieux solliciter des dons.
En un an, il a ainsi aidé
dececentaines d'Ukrainiens
à quitter leur domicile
devenu trop dangereux.
Comme ce couple de retraités
en banlieue de Bakhmout,
évacué le 22 janvier.
Mais escorter les gens près
de la ligne de front en Ukraine,
c'est aussi prendre des risques.
(explosion)
(cris d'alerte, en anglais)
Ses amis Chris Parry
et Andrew Bagshaw n'ont pas eu
la même chance, tous deux tués
à Soledar le 6 janvier dernier
alors qu'ils allaient évacuer
des civils.
Mais peu importe le danger,
Daniel Wilk ne se voit pas
partir, pas tant que la guerre
perdure et qu'il y aura
des civils à protéger.
(exclamation attendrie)
Daniel Wilk ne craint
qu'une chose : que cette guerre
se banalise aux yeux
des Occidentaux et
qu'ils s'en désintéressent.
Aussi lance-t-il un message
aux Canadiens.